the left's love affair with the nation's
deadliest criminal gang continues
tonight the howls of outrage
reverberating president Trump dared
criticize ms-13 by calling them animals
watch he basically seems to assume that
everybody is part of ms-13 very strange
to here with President United States
speak in such dehumanizing terms clearly
the president wants a war against
Latinos you might make that distinction
between members of ms-13 and the rest of
the Latino community in the rest of the
immigrant community
I assure you that most of Americans
don't make that distinction when he says
were animals when he says we're animals
things are moving fast in this country
by 2020 defending central american
street gangs likely be a key plank in
the democratic platform it's close now
you can see it maybe Bernie Sanders will
feel the burn a little more literally
camel Harris's campaign will certainly
be stronger together with the added
muscle of guatemalan street gangs don't
laugh it's actually more plausible than
you think it is don't believe us here's
what CNN contributor Anna Navarro said
this Wednesday about Trump's animal
remark quote Trump is in very bad
company Nazis referred to Jews as rats
slave owners viewed slaves as subhuman
animals now here's what Navarro herself
had to say about Trump just two years
ago quote should Trump drop out of the
race yes he should drop out of the human
race he's an animal apologies to animals
apparently Donald Trump can mean to
humanize and that's fine ms-13 though a
gang that butchers high schoolers with
machetes that's too far but on the Left
that's exactly the state of play as of
this evening ms-13 runs drugs of course
it commits murders and it terrorizes
entire immigrant communities but they
don't ask questions about diversity so
they're okay
questioning diversity is the highest
crime you can commit according to the
left question diversity imperils their
entire worldview it suggests that people
are not interchangeable in the
particular people who inhabit a
particular country matter that's
unacceptable far more unacceptable than
say murder
a teenager in Long Island that doesn't
even warrant a serious attempt at
deportation joining us is Leslie
Marshall she's a progressive radio show
host in a keen observer for the
Democratic Party was it good to see it
good to see you Tucker
so you're seeing all the leaders of the
Democratic Party Schumer Pelosi it's
surrogates the entire American news
media virtually singing from the same
song sheet this is a coordinated
storyline who thought of this what
consultant convinced Democrats running
in defense of ms-13 was a good way to go
into the midterms well first of all I
think it was very clear quite frankly
and I know fellow Democrats get angry at
me that the president was answering a
question that the sheriff posed
regarding the gang members the issue
here Tucker is not supportive gangs or
gang members I have an 11 year old son
and as you know ms-13 starts as young as
11 and goes up to 40 it's calling human
beings animals now wait a minute I know
when you look at what ms-13 does it's
hard to say well are they human beings
when you have an 11 year old child who
was fearful for their and their family's
life in a very impoverished area and you
think how can I protect myself and
you're offered protection by some of
these older ms-13 gang members
regardless of the fact they're going to
beat you to a pulp or perhaps even take
your life in 13 seconds very slow 13
seconds you look to them because you
think how can I be considered tough how
can I in my family not right right I
don't think those 11-year old children
are quite frankly our animals and I
don't think we should refer to human
beings even if they're bad human beings
as animals well but look people have all
kinds of reasons for doing what they do
and sometimes it's understandable but I
mean people had reasons for becoming
concentration camp guards but if I call
the concentration camp guard an animal
you would say you know he's not strictly
speaking an animal he's a human being
but I get it he's horrible like you're
you're expressing your outrage at what
he does if I said that no one would bat
an eye but that's because concentration
camp guards aren't potential Democratic
voters I mean this is really about
winning up a constituency isn't it this
is a political decision Democrats have
made we're on the side of ms-13 not cuz
we love murder I'm not saying Democrats
love murder I don't think they do but
they
want to alienate anybody on that side
including I guess ms-13 members
themselves I mean let's be honest about
what's happening I don't agree with you
there although we are certainly in an
era where left or right a lot of things
come into the landscape and our argued
for a political gain especially midterm
elections coming up I don't think that's
the the point here at all Tucker I mean
you know that we liberals claim to be
pacifist we claim to care about everyone
and it is the terminology that is very
unsettling how do a lot of people in the
Democratic yes liberals are passive look
those are pushing I mean you're watching
liberals across the spectrum from you
know nikki Haley to Chuck Schumer
pushing for more war in Syria they're
bloodthirsty actually Haley start
wearing a democratic cape I must have
missed that one just started pushing for
more pointless worse but here here's the
point if I came out and described a
concentration camp guard as an animal
nobody would have a problem with it I
certainly wouldn't have a problem with
that you would no normal person would
have a problem with that normal people
don't defend murderers but the
Democratic Party is defending ms-13 and
I'm just making a political observation
which is that's not a wise strategy
going into election because normal
people aren't going to go for that are
they I'm gonna go back to your
concentration camp argument okay well
being that I have one Jewish parent I
think you know and being that I have
religious that did parish in
concentration camps there were there
were a few types of guards in the camps
quite frankly one would be fellow Jews
who wanted to survive and have a lot of
guilt and there are many documentaries
about that too
okay there are many people that said
they were just following orders they
were not referred to as animals and
quite frankly many of them escaped any
type of criminal look I I don't want to
get off on a World War two tangent I and
that was one of a hundred examples
Jeffrey Dahmer you know anybody who
commits murder for the pleasure of
committing it I think it's fair to
criticize in the harshest possible terms
and it would be surprising if an entire
political party came to that person's
aid and defense as the Democrats now are
two ms-13 and I'm just asking like whose
idea was this is not happening
accidentally when you
harwood from the New York Times in Chuck
Schumer and Nancy Pelosi saying exactly
the same thing somebody thought up this
line and I'm just wondering do you think
it's a smart thing to say I don't think
anybody thought up the line I think what
happens and it's happening almost every
day is the president says something or
tweet something and then there's a
reaction and certainly there's a strong
reaction on the left and there's been a
reaction in the Latino community because
you know a lot of the headlines were
that the president said this about all
immigrants at first and then when people
read the transcript or they listened to
the actual taping of what occurred in
that meeting then it became more clear
that he was speaking about ms-13 and it
was response by the sheriff's question
regarding him as 13 but you also have to
remember talker some people that are in
ms-13 in this country begging not to be
deported aren't a part of the gang they
just can't get out cuz the only way out
is to be killed but let me ask you this
the the final question but this is the
deep irony undergirding all of this
which is ms-13 preys upon immigrants who
do you think their victims are
overwhelmingly Honduran Salvadoran
immigrants often illegal by the way so
if you say if Democrats say you know we
are the champions of immigrants why are
they defending people who prey upon
immigrants it doesn't my any sense
I don't feel that Democrats are in any
way defending murderers I feel that
Democrats are saying that the
president's choice of words was not
palatable for them and that no human
being how terrible human being they
maybe should be called an animal because
an animal doesn't shoes their lifetime
but hold on let's be honest they're
holding the President to a different
standard in the holding ms-13 if you
came out and said Trump is an animal I
don't think for a second Nancy Pelosi
would give you a lecture about
Christianity or whatever she was
pretending to believe the other day the
Spirit of God in every part I mean they
would just they would even notice it
because they think Trump is an animal
right but they're offended when you say
that about a Salvadoran street gang I
mean since your question honestly I'm
not the fan of the president but I would
defend him if somebody called him I
don't think a human being should be
called that and a person should be and I
hope you
rika-chan out said i can't even remember
her name but that's CNN contributors
oh it's getting crazy on TV who called a
banana anyway Leslie thank you it's
great to see you